what's going on it's shador Sanders it's
Travis Hunter we right here s court side
with bleach report I'm excited to see
this NBA game tonight this my first one
this my first one ready to see LeBron
and yish go at it we like LeBron and D
way it's got to be LeBron and D yeah I
would say that for sure I'll say that or
like Steph Curry and uh playay who the
shooter me look where he shooting
from all right now he just being o
though all the people on the court right
now good as hell you score on them I
don't know I got to get on the court
with him big tall giant running down the
court I a know they play music while
they play oh my God what's up bro we
they put us on the
big not to bad them so what you doing
what's up what's up so what you think
you doing dog you think you doing
Y how you doing man you we got buckets
of popcorn what we need whatever you
need we good over here we got that Prime
Time right there give me my
music wait a
[Applause]
minute Gucci bang tell them they ain't
got nothing to do with you down
there I like when LeBron get
mad
[Applause]
oh man time out man got leave man oh my
God man time out
man let me f that b let me that b hey Mr
where we need some new basketball we
need some grip on that ball bro that
ball too sniffy bro how the hell they
play with that that sh feel like an
outside ball that's a
bucket he not missing bro he's wet now
he need a 993 on 2K young man that made
that three he said I did my job for the
day I'm done you basketball watch film
yeah they got plays who jersey
with probably Jamal Murray though Jamal
Murray is a bucket too though damn I
heard that way over here I heard that
over here ref what's
up
UCL man call them fouls
man who's your daddy
[Music]
love y boys
man you got send JY got get us right I'm
send y your own package I send
everything to office for y Jersey
everything I got take
[Applause]
care all right
man nuggets one
I him that